يَا بابا رَنَّ الهَاتِفْ
أَجِبْهُ لَيس هُنَا
بابا رَنَّ الهَاتِفْ
عُذْرًا عَمُّو آَسِفْ يَقُولُ لَيْسَ هُنَا
تا تي تا تو  تبرتا تا تا تو
إِنَّكَ بَابَا تُخْبِرُنَا  طُولَ الوَقْتِ تُعَلِّمُنَا
أَنَّ الكَذابَ مَعْيُوبْ
مَذْمُومٌ دَوْمًا مِنَّا
إِنَّكَ بابا تُحَيِّرُنَا
يَا بابا رَنَّ الهَاتِفْ
أَجِبْهُ لَيس هُنَا
يَا بابا أَنْتَ القُدْوَةْ نَقْتَبِسُ بِفِعْلِكَ أُسْوَة
بابا أَنْتَ القُدْوَةْ نَقْتَبِسُ بِفِعْلِكَ أُسْوَة
قَدْ قُلْتَ بِأَنَ الصِّدْقَ هُوَمِنْ أَخْلاَقِ الصَّفْوَةْ
يَابَابَا رَنَّ الهَاتِفْ
تا تي تا تو  تبرتا تا تا تو
يَا بابا هَذا هَامْ قَدْ قُلْتَ الكَذبُ حَرَامْ
تَنْهَانَا عَنْهُ دَوْمًا
لَوْ حَتَّى فِي الَكلاَمْ
يا بابا رن الهاتف
أجبه ليس هنا
بابا رن الهاتف
عذرا عمو آسف
يقول ليس هنا
فهو يقول ليس هنا
تا تي تا تو  تبرتا تا تا تو
يَا بابا مَاذَا نَفْعَلْ إِنَّ الصِّدْقَ هُوَ الأَجْمَلْ
بابا مَاذَا نَفْعَلْ إِنَّ الصِّدْقَ هُوَ الأَجْمَلْ
هَلْ تَذْكُرُ مَا تُخْبِرُنَا  يَا بَابَا لاَ تَتَعَلَّلْ
لاَ تَنْسى ذَلكَ أَفْضَلْ
يا بابا رن الهاتف
حسنا أجبه أنا هنا
ههههههههااااايييي